- [Interviewer] What kind of
levers does the Speaker have
in relation to the other
House representatives?
- The Speaker has all kinds of levers,
both formal and informal.
In fact, a lot of them are informal.
So, the Speaker can, Speaker
names a lot of people
to the committees,
particularly to the, quote,
the Rules Committee in the House.
And what does the Rules Committee do?
The Rules Committee sets
the rules for what's debated
and what comes onto the floor.
And so, through controlling
the Rules Committee,
you can control what kinds
of amendments come up,
how much debate there
is for unpopular ideas,
and you can help get legislation through
by managing the rules
under which it's debated.
There's a famous instance
in which Dennis Hastert,
who was Speaker of the
House under George W. Bush,
held open a vote on Medicare Part D.
This was adding prescription
drugs to the Medicare Plan.
And what holding open
a vote means is you set
a certain time for the
number of votes that come in.
And at the end of that
time, you count the votes,
are they in, does it pass.
Well, it wasn't passing.
And so, Hastert let the vote
stay open while he went around
and strong-armed individual
members of the Republican side,
he was a Republican
Speaker, strong-armed them,
said, "You really gotta vote for this,"
and finally got enough votes,
and just when it went over the threshold,
boom, he closed the window,
said, "The vote's over," and it passed.
And what did he do to
get those extra votes?
Well, you can give people
plum committee assignments,
you can help their
legislation get to the floor
that maybe wasn't getting
there fast enough.
And the other powers you have
is you can go raise money
for them or get the people
you know on the political side
to make their run for reelection easier.
So, there are lot of gifts
you can give to your members
or things you can withhold from them
to make them do what you want.